pas encore adopté est déjà contestée le
12 juillet dernier emmanuel macron
évoque pour la première fois la mise en
place d'un pass sanitaire dès le 21
juillet le pass sanitaire sera étendue
au lieu des loisirs et de culture seuls
les vaccinés et les personnes testées
négatives pourront accéder à ces lieux
qu'ils cinq jours plus tard les
premières mobilisations partout le même
refrain repris en choeur par une
centaine de milliers de français
je suis pas anti vaccins je suis pas
complotistes je suis pas anti masque je
suis pour la liberté vaccinale est donc
vraiment il ya le sujet il n'est pas sur
les mesures sanitaires il est sur la
privation de liberté jusqu'à présent les
citoyens sont égaux élire avec le pass 1
vidéo
on va vers la disparition de la liberté
et l'égalité des citoyens est-ce qu'il
faut détruire la démocratie sous
prétexte la maladie est là faut-il
détruire la cohésion nationale je crois
pas je crois qu'on va trop loin divisez
le parlement vote tout de même l'entrée
en vigueur du passani terre le 25
juillet dernier pour 156 contre 60 le
projet de loi est adopté au prix de 60
heures d'échangés quelques modifications
de textes existent notamment la menace
de licenciement pour les salariés
réfractaire visé par l'obligation
vaccinale les soignants sont eux en
première ligne nous a envoyés dans les
services alors qu'on était positif au
coït qu'on avait des symptômes et
pourtant nous envoyer travailler et
maintenant on nous rend responsable de
la situation alors que
plus grands responsables ces
gouvernements c'est le gouvernement qui
a fermé 1800 lit pendant la période de
vide il ya vingt mille hospitaliers qui
ont quitté leur travail pendant la
période commises c'est en imposant la
vaccination
c'est ce qui risque de se passer encore
cédé des collègues qui vont quitter
l'hôpital et ça on peut pas l'accepter
le 9 août le pass sanitaire devient
officiellement effectifs dans les bars
et restaurants les transports ou encore
les centres commerciaux
avec parfois quelques couennes
et hilario n'y passe pas avec l'appareil
l'avant par éthylique mon certificat
n'est pas bon pourtant un certificat
comique bacha et puis les jaunes
personnalités politiques de l'opposition
se joignent au mouvement bravo vous est
d'ores et déjà des milliers et des
milliers à vous battre pour la liberté
la mobilisation gagne en intensité il
faut retirer cette loi de la honte et il
faut gérer autrement mais chose et pour
le salut appelait il faut gérer
sereinement cette affaire en ciblant les
personnes vulnérables en les traitant en
rouvrant des lits à l'hôpital faisant
confiance aux médecins aux soignants
tomber dans l'hystérie la diact ça
suffit mais en se lève en l'autre dans
notre 15e c'est cool les gens sont là
très nombreux l'esa
à l'entendre malgré quelques incidents
les six premiers week-end de
mobilisation se sont plutôt déroulée
dans le calme de l'aveu même des forces
de l'ordre des forces de l'ordre qui
craignent en revanche une radicalisation
du mouvement septembre après un été déjà
bien chargé